this movie is uh [ __ ] crazy because
seth uh
he's in the 1920s and he's working in a
pickle factory and it's really funny
because
his whole job in the pickle factory is
to kill mice
the mice chase him into the pickle that
i love that the mice win and they they
actually kill you
[Laughter]
and he kind of gets pickled and then he
wakes up a hundred years later and it's
really fun it is a funny premise because
it's like well what if you met
your great-great-great-grandfather he'd
probably think you were an [ __ ]
because you couldn't do anything with
your hands
like in the movie the only thing that's
impressive to herschel is that
his great-grandson has access to
sparkling water like that to him is like
the pinnacle of
success and what he doesn't get is i
mean today
you know sparkling water is not that
hard to come by and the things that
actually are hurt to come by today
are completely unimpressive i was
impressed with your acting
i'm gonna tell you something you played
two roles
it's a movie about his great great great
grandfather and the grandson and he
plays both guys
but your accent as a polish immigrant
is pretty [ __ ] good i mean it was
something i was honestly very worried
about and something that
oh playing two both the roles overall
was something that it literally took me
years to decide whether or not it was a
good idea because
like cinematically there's like a pretty
dodgy
history of actors playing both roles and
comedically
there's like a dodgy history of actors
doing like
accents basically the idea that made me
think it was a good idea was this idea
that is a theme in the movie that just
like you
are your ancestors whether you like it
or not
and i think everyone has that picture of
their grandfather their great
grandfather grandmother
great-grandmother
when they are their same age as they are
now and they can't help but think
what would it be like if we knew each
other at the same age you know i would
picture my
grandfather when he was in the navy in
his mid-20s and every time i look
at it i think if he knew me while we
were both in our mid-20s he would
have beaten the living [ __ ] out of me
yeah he'd smack you right in the head
i would have been the most annoying
[ __ ] to him
what's with all this weed and making
ashtray
go fight the nazis you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]